the bigger picture of this is you're an
outspoken critic of uh pharmaceutical
companies big Pharma
what is the biggest problem with big
Pharma and how can it be fixed
well the problem could be fixed with
regulation you know on the problems but
the pharmaceutical industry is
um
is uh I mean I don't want to say because
this is going to seem extreme that a
criminal Enterprise
if you look at the history that is an
applicable
um
descript or characterization for example
the four biggest vaccine makers
sanofi Merck Pfizer and glaxone four
companies that make all of the 72
vaccines that are now mandated for
America effectively mandated for
American children
collectively those companies have paid
35 billion dollars in criminal penalties
and damages in the last decade
and I think since 2000 about 79 billion
so these are the most corrupt companies
in the world
and the problem is that they're serial
felons
they you know they do this again and
again and again so
it did I you know America did viohawks
which
vioxx they you know they killed people
by falsifying science
and they did it they lied to the public
they said this is a headache medicine
and
um an arthritis painkiller
but they didn't tell people that it also
gave you heart attacks and they knew you
know we've found when we sued them on
their you know the memos from their Bean
counters saying we're going to kill this
many people but we're still going to
make money
so they make those calculations and
those calculations are made very very
regularly
and then you know when they
um when they get caught they they pay a
penalty and I think they paid about
seven billion dollars
um for viox but then they went right
back that same year that they paid that
penalty
they went back into the same thing again
with Gardasil and with a whole lot of
other uh drugs so
the way that the system is set up the
way that it sold to doctors the way that
um nobody ever goes to jail so there's
really no penalty that uh It all becomes
part of the cost of doing business
and you know you can see other
businesses that if they're not if they
don't if there's no penalty if there's
no real I mean look
these are the companies that gave us the
opioid epidemic right so they knew what
was going to happen and we you know you
go and see there's a documentary I
forget what the name of it is but
it shows exactly what happened and you
know they corrupted FDA
they knew that this that oxycodone was
addictive they got FDA to tell doctors
that it wasn't addictive
they pressured FDA to lie and they got
their way and they've so far they left
this year you know those
they got a whole generation addicted
toxicodone and now you know when they
got caught and they made it we made it
harder to get oxycodone and now all
those addicted kids
are going to Fentanyl and dying and this
year it killed 106 106 000 oh that's
twice as many people who were killed
during the Vietnam during the 20-year
Vietnam War but in one year twice many
American Kids
and they knew it was going to happen
and they did it to make money so I don't
know what you call that other than
saying that's you know a criminal
Enterprise was it possible to have
within a capitalist system to produce
medication to produce drugs at scale in
a way that is not corrupt
of course it is how
uh you know through a solid regulatory
regimen
you know where drugs are actually tested
well you know I mean the problem is
not the capitalist system the capitalist
system I you know I have great
admiration for that love for the
capitalist system is the greatest
economic engine ever devise
but it has to be harnessed to a social
purpose
otherwise it's going to it leads us you
know down the
trail of of oligarchy environmental
destruction and you know and
commoditizing poisoning and uh and
killing human beings that's what it will
do and in the end
you need a regulatory structure
that is
um that is not
uh corrupted
I entanglements Financial entanglements
with the industry
and we've set this up the way that this
is that the system is set up today
has created this system of
regulatory capture on steroids
so almost 50 percent of fda's budget
comes from pharmaceutical companies
the people who work at FDA are you know
their money is coming their salaries are
coming from Pharma half their salaries
oh they're you know they know who their
bosses are and that means getting those
drugs done getting them out the tour and
approved as quickly as possible it's
called Fast Track approval and they pay
50 50 of fda's budget
goes about 45 actually goes to Fast
Track approval do you think money can
buy Integrity oh yeah of course it can
and right right yeah I mean there's
that's not something that is that is
controversial of course it will so and
that's controversial to me I would like
to think that scientists
I'm talking about population wide I'm
not talking about the individual but I'd
like to believe that scientists
I mean it in general a career of a
scientist is not a very high paying job
I'd like to believe that people that go
into science that work at FDA they work
at NIH are doing it for a reason that's
not even correlated with money really
yeah
and I think probably that's why they go
in there but scientists are corruptable
and you know I the way and the way that
I can tell you that is that I've brought
over 500 losses and almost all of them
involve scientific controversies and
there are scientists on both sides in
everyone
and when I was when we said Monsanto
there was uh on the Monsanto side there
was a Yale scientist a Stanford
scientist and a Harvard scientist and on
RSI there was the Yale Stanford and
Harvard scientists and they were
televised saying exactly the opposite
things
in fact there's a word for those kind of
scientists who take money for their
opinion and the words by ostitutes
and they are very very common and you
know and I've been dealing them with
with them my whole career you know I
think it was Upton Sinclair who said
that it's very
um difficult to persuade a man of a fact
if the existence of that fact will
diminish his salary and I think that's
true for all of us if they you know we
find a way of reconciling ourselves
the things that are
the truth that actually and World Views
and actually benefit our our salaries
now NIH
um NIH has probably the worst system
which is that scientists who work for
NIH NIH itself which used to be the
premier gold standard scientific agency
in the world everybody looked at NIH
stat today it's just an incubator for
pharmaceutical drugs and and you know
that is that gravity of economic
self-interest because if you're
um if NIH itself collects uh royalties
they have margin rights for the patents
on all the drugs that they work on so
with the modern vaccine which they
promoted incessantly and aggressively
NIH on 50 of That vaccine is making
billions and billions of dollars on it
and there are four at least four
scientists that we know of and probably
at least six
at NIH who themselves have margin rights
for those patents so if you are a
scientist who work at NIH you work on a
new drug you you then get margin rights
and you're entitled to royalties 150 000
a year forever from that forever your
children your children's children as
long as that uh products on the market
you can collect royalties
so you have you know the modern vaccine
is paying for the top people at NIH you
know some of the top regulators
is paying for their boats it's paying
for their mortgages paying for their
children's education
and you know you have to expect
that the uh that in those kind of
situations the regulatory function would
be
um subsumed beneath the Mercantile
Ambitions of the agency itself and the
individuals who stand to profit
enormously from getting a drug to Market
those guys are paid
by us the taxpayer to find problems with
those drugs before they get to Market
but if you know that drug is going to
pay for your mortgage you may Overlook a
little problem and that we're even a
very big one
and that's the problem